en mayo de 2020 eeuu estalló en
protestas anti racistas y contra la
brutalidad policial la muerte del afro
estadounidense 'george floyd a manos de
un policía blanco motivó a miles de
personas a salir a las calles a pedir
cambios reales
las manifestaciones se replicaron en el
mundo y llevaron a que estados y
ciudades estadounidenses aprobaran en
total 140 reformas de los cuerpos
policiales hoy entra en su fase final
el juicio contra derecho bing el ex
policía acusado del asesinato de
floribert pero me dice sabrán que el 25
de mayo de 2020 el señor del ex joven
traicionó su placa cuando usó una fuerza
excesiva e injustificada contra el
cuerpo del señor george floyd apoyando
la rodilla contra su cuello y su espalda
hasta que el último aliento de vida
salió de su cuerpo la defensa se basa en
que la actuación del ex agente se ajustó
al entrenamiento policial de sus 19 años
de carrera sin embargo el jefe del
cuerpo de minneápolis
y continuar aplicando tal nivel de
fuerza a una persona que estaba boca
abajo enmanillado y que no reacciona de
ninguna manera corresponde con nuestro
reglamento ni con nuestros valores por
otro lado los abogados de la ex policía
también alegan que floyd murió a causa
del consumo de drogas algo que el jefe
de la unidad forense del condado negó
mantengo lo que escribió en el informe
del pasado julio fue un paro cardio
pulmonar durante el proceso el jurado
también escuchó a los testigos que
presenciaron los últimos instantes de
vida de floyd muchos de ellos todavía en
estado de conmoción mis padres hermanos
y amigos son negros podrían haber sido
ellos he pasado muchas noches pidiendo
perdón a georg floyd por no haber hecho
nada más por salvar su vida
quien no aportó su versión fue el
expolicía que se acogió a su derecho a
no declarar
me acogeré al privilegio que me otorga
la quinta enmienda según cifras del new
york times' desde que empezó el juicio
contra el joven el 29 de marzo 64
personas es decir 3 por día han muerto
en encuentros con la policía la mayoría
de las víctimas fueron afro
estadounidenses y latinos